[Music]
2005 Shadow of the Colossus was a
revelation a game whose gorgeous
aesthetic and reserved tone were at the
time undeniably distinct together with
its unique take on boss encounters and a
stirring soundtrack it was a defining
title of the PlayStation 2 euro but it
was also a game infamous for its
technical issues most notably it's
choppy aggravating framerate a 2011 HD
remaster for the ps3 alleviated the
title of this significant tarnish and
now with 2018 shut up the Colossus for
PlayStation 4 Blue Point games have
completely rebuilt every aspect of the
games world while leaving its underlying
structure and mechanics intact a move
which not only enhances the game
visually but uncatted godly intensifies
the utter majesty of this extraordinary
experience
for those unfamiliar Shadow of the
Colossus takes place in an ancient world
where young warrior Wanda and his horse
augur transport a deceased loved one to
a forbidden sealed land armed with only
a sword and bow wander hopes to take
advantage of a fable that suggests that
something in this isolated province has
the means to bring back the dead there
he encounters an omnipresent entity who
compels him to destroy 16 colossi hidden
throughout the territory in order to
enable his wish if you've already played
a previous version of Shadow of the
Colossus you'll find that blue points
where Nishan feels much the same barring
some minor differences in controller
mapping some subtle quality of life
tweaks and a new easter egg the
locations of each Colossus and their
method of defeat remain the same as do
the locations of every white-tailed
lizard and fruit collectible the weight
and movement physics of Wanda and Argo
feel unchanged and new game+ rewards are
identical but the impact of this
completely rebuilt world is transcendent
this is a world that is geographically
as you remember but one that constantly
astounds you as if seeing it for the
first time highly detailed environment
modeling in tandem with impressive light
and shadow simulation bring amazing life
to the game's breathtaking biomes
luscious forests are densely packed with
majestically tall trees and twisting
foliage dappled beautifully with soft
rays of sunlight vast arid deserts feel
horribly desolate as you try and sight
somber ruins through a wispy sandstorm
even the simple side of mountainous
crags and cliff faces is impressive with
shadows acutely defining their rocky
surfaces making them pop ominously every
place you travel to in this world every
time you crest a hill emerge from a
crevasse or change or perspective the
landscape will be a sight worthy of
pores
the increased fidelity of the
reconstruction colossi is just as
spectacular and the mere sight of one in
this version of the game is even more
inspiring than it is in your memory each
fo some small and nimble the rest
impossibly Titanic and overbearing is a
terrifying beast of stone fur and
leather that fur is now noticed ly more
dense and luscious and hanging onto it
for dear life as your enemy tries to
violently shake you off feels even more
intense these moments are enhanced by
the increased fidelity of the
environment that lies far beneath you
went on top of a colossus combined with
motion effects which amplify the sense
of danger at these dizzying heights the
first time I mounted a flying claws in
this version of the game I could feel my
chest wrench as I answer Slee squeeze my
controllers to hold onto its wing for
dear life while it soared and flat
wildly through the air
it was truly exhilarating playing on a
ps4 Pro offers you the ability to
further enhance visual fidelity by a
high dynamic range color as well as the
choice between two different graphical
options with different priorities
cinematic mode enables 4k resolutions on
4k screens as well as allowing for
impressive down sampling for 1080
displays at a targeted 30fps performance
mode provides less impressive graphical
quality but maintains a smoother
framerate targeting 60fps in my
experience I prefer the crisper image
offered in cinematic mode once you
realize that you can recognize the
definition between each individual blade
of grass it's hard to let that go
however the visual quality offered by
both modes still enhances the experience
of the game in ways previously mentioned
especially for those whose last memory
of it was suffering through subsidy
Affairs framerate issues on the original
ps2 release
[Music]
it is so fortunate that this visual
reconstruction doesn't detract from what
makes shout of the Colossus a great
achievement the game's holistic and
understated direction still comes
through incredibly it's muted colors
cinematic camera angles and a stock
absence of music while exploring the
world still evokes a poignant tone of
desolation and solitude the walls large
forsaken landscape doesn't feel bereft
of things to do because simply riding
through it and enjoying the majesty of
the land accompanied only by the sound
of augo's hooves scraping against the
earth it's a delightfully meditative
experience fighting a colossus is still
a grand solemn and tense challenge that
is exhilarating to overcome the
impassioned orchestral soundtrack
heightens the pressure of every maneuver
working out how to mount the impossibly
enormous enemy clambering to reach their
vulnerabilities as they try to fling you
off and driving a sword into their flesh
every moment of a colossus battle is
thrilling to execute and witness whether
you're doing it for the first time or
the 15th time in a postgame Time Trial
while the passing of 12 years hasn't
affected the overall quality of Shadow
of the Colossus there are two technical
annoyances that persist and remind you
of a bygone era the third-person camera
system doesn't clip through world
objects so it becomes erratic and
troublesome to adjust when moving
through enclosed spaces or near a solid
object
additionally the game's unforgiving
climbing system which asks you to jump
with the X button and grasp onto a ledge
or surface with the r2 trigger is
occasionally temperamental there may be
times when contact with the ledge may
not correctly register even though you
may have been holding on to well in
advance and correctly estimated your
distance needed for the jump however
both of these issues affect only a small
amount of time of the game and should
not be considered a significant strike
in the case of the climbing system it's
a quirk which is easy to come to peace
with because of how absolutely essential
the mechanic is to creating the rousing
pressure and suspense of Colossus and
counties
Shadow of the Colossus is a tremendous
journey and one well worth taking and
retaking the visual level hole is simply
stunning and thoroughly enhances every
facet of wonder and Nagas excellent
adventure galloping through the wealth
is always breathtaking and felling a
monumental Colossus is always humbling
Shadow of the Colossus is a beautiful
reconstruction of an already exceptional
title it continues to be a modern
classic and is an extraordinary game
that everyone must experience